why don't you tell us a little bit about
yourself I'm an actor obviously I want
to thank the entire cast and crew this
belongs to you as much as it does me
tell us about that HBO show it must be
amazing what a week Jared Leto um no
that's my sister Amy I'm Polly cuff fit
she has a twin thanks so much yeah
coming in I mean technically we're
identical and you're both actors Summer
Street weren't you for a six-week gets
tu characters some whatever by noon like
packing up working out the sisters no a
nervous difficult to do she's just got
it
that's me has been cast in a television
program congratulations about the
daughter not this one
you think I'm talented I eat all those
last thing you did what about my
one-woman show of 12 Angry Men
is that all you've done it's the owner
from some aspect is much better than I
thought it was gonna be good for just
kind of something here there's no point
having both of you on the boats but I'm
the cool one
I could dye my hair I'll go straight to
LA the policies there I'm going to
Hollywood you have representation here
in the United States know any audition
no meetings no you have any idea what
you're doing
oh really
[Music]
you've made it that's what you care
about you even enjoy a see all your
dreams you can be anything you want
[Music]
if I can make it before I die
[Music]
what told me you behind I'm not a child
Jenny money for a taxi yes please
you